j'ai couru mille fois sur ce circuit en
jouant laisse-moi conduire à ma façon
je crois que parce que tu joues à tes
jeux de courte voiture tu vas devenir
pilote de course pour de vrai
es
sont des professionnels ça marchera pas
la trouille
j'ai toujours voulu devenir pilote de
course
je vais le faire que tu crois en moi ou
pas
[Musique]
au monde
on vous offre une chance de courir en
professionnel
c'est pas un jeu vidéo
c'est la réalité
un bonus en faisant ça dans ton jeu
refait ce genre d'erreur et tu pourrais
bien y laisser ta peau
je sais ce que je fais j'ai pas peur
j'ai couru 1000 fois sur ce circuit en
jouant laisse-moi conduire à ma façon
j'avoue que c'était bien vu
imitation tu es dans la cour des grands
les autres pilotes les membres de ton
équipe ils vont pas t'avoir à la bonne
c'est
facile avec un joystick
tu vas leur prouver à tous que tu es à
ta place
je sais que tu as peur
[Musique]
pour ça
oui chef
[Musique]
super
je perds beaucoup plus qu'une course
alors je vais pas rembourser
allons étonné le monde